ils vont en voir nous a écrit pour
savoir combien est-ce que ça ferait un
troisième
la première réponse très courte et on ne
le sait pas du tout la réponse un peu
plus longue c'est sa dépense
deux projets et ça dépend de son
emplacement je vous explique on sait pas
encore si ça va être bon
ce tunnel où elle personnel
et en ce moment québec étudie simple
core izard potentiel donc pour un lien
de transport routier entre la rive-sud
et la rive-nord de québec quatre sur
cinq de ces emplacements sont à l'aise
de québec 1 à l'horizon
du côté des partis politiques québec
solidaire du mouvement veut pas de
troisième mais on peut faire le
transport en commun
le parti québécois dire nous on veut
attendre la conclusion des études en pur
peut se décider pour se prononcer la
coalition avenir québec de son côté vip
nous ce qui est sûr c'est que ça va être
un troisième à l'est et nous sous un
gouvernement qu'à question n'était
lussas frais les travaux d un premier
mandat alors que le parti libéral d'ipo
avant 2026 et on va attendre la
conclusion des études pour décider de
l'emplacement
alors si on vient au pourquoi est ce que
ça coûterait on peut estimer en moins
quelques milliards de dollars pense au
pont champlain côté 4,1 milliards de
dollars de juste
le maire de québec régis labeaume qui
s'est risqué à évaluer une facture
parlant de peut-être jusqu'à 10
milliards de dollars
oubliez que monsieur labeaume lui
souhaiterait que ce 3ème bien se farcit
à l'ouest qui nous dirait qu'il faut
vouloir attendre le 1er octobre
déclare vous avez d'autres questions
écrivez nous les commentaires à aux
élections @ sa radio présidentielle